ça c'est vraiment des organes de réserve
primitifs qui vont après
de la sauce pas toujours découverte
d'une production horticole pour les
curieux de nature dans ses serres de
l'arboretum de Versailles chèvreloux
près de 60 000 végétaux sont semés à la
main chaque année pour fleurir le Jardin
des Plantes à Paris visite et ateliers
sont organisés au fil des saisons pour
présenter les coulisses de cette
activité les dernières années ont été
difficiles avec le covid et le on sent
quand même que le public voilà un besoin
en retour à la nature à toucher voilà
mettre les mains à la terre produire
essayer arrosage température luminosité
hygrométrie c'est cette jardinière bon
pu découvrir les secrets d'un
ensemencement professionnel chaque
graine est plantée grâce à un bâtonnet
imbibé d'eau afin de faciliter la prise
nous avons montré différentes techniques
et surtout essayer de donner des
conseils pour que le public puisse
ensuite établir leur semis à la maison
et avoir un maximum de chances
d'obtenir de bons résultats grâce à au
conseil donné aujourd'hui c'est très
délicat parce que j'ai fait des
tentatives de germination chez moi et
bon bah j'ai fait des erreurs et je vais
les rectifier après la théorie place à
la pratique chacun a pu essayer à
l'argus semi en pot et repartir avec le
fruit de son travail encore un petit peu
oui
j'ai choisi des reines Marguerite et des
Zinnia qui sont des fleurs très
décoratives qui montent à 70 cm de haut
et qui vont embellir mon jardin dans peu
de temps j'espère une prochaine visite
des serres horticole sera organisée ce
mercredi 3 mai au Chesnay rock en cours
l'occasion de faire monter en graine ses
connaissances botaniques